[موسيقى]
مطابقه اوقاتكم اهلا بكم الى نشره اخباريه
من العربيه نبداها بابرز العناوين
في انتخابات الكونجرس الامريكيه
الجمهوريون يقتربون من اغلبيه مجلس النواب
والمنافسه محتدمه على مجلس الشيوخ
الرئيس يتعاهد بالعمل لاعادهم عوده ترامب
الى البيت الابيض والاخير في مرمى
انتقادات الجمهوريين
بعد اعلان انسحابها الدفاع البريطانيه
تقول ان روسيا دمر الجسور ورائها في خير
سولي اطفاء تقدم اوكرانيا
السلطات الايرانيه تعتقل مذيعا وتتهممه
بالعماله ونشطاء يتظاهرون رغم تهديدات
وزير المخابرات وقائد الجيش
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم نبدا الساعه الاخباريه من
العربيه مع قراءه قراءه في نتائج
الانتخابات النصفيه الامريكيه التي تدخل
امطارها الاخيره حيث كشفت النتائج عن تقدم
خفيف للجمهوريين على الديمقراطيين حتى
الان فيما تم الاعلان عنه في مجلس الشيوخ
يحتل الجمهوريون 49 مقعدا فيما حصد
الديمقراطيون 48 مقعدا وذلك بعد ان فاز
الجمهوريون في ولايه ويسكنزون تتبقى الان
ثلاث مقاعد في مجلس الشيوخ غير محسومه هي
في جورجيا اريزونا ونيفادا في اريزونا
يتقدم الديمقراطيون عبر سنه الحالي ماركلي
على الجمهوريه المدعوم من ترامب
ولكن اعلان النتائج النهائيه قد يتاخر
بسبب مشاكل تقنيه تسببت في اغلاق ابواب
اللجان في احدى المقاطعات الامر الذي اغضب
الجمهوريين اما الحزم الحقيقي فمن المتوقع
ان يكون في جورجيا ونفاده في الاخيره
يتقدم الجمهوريه ادم لاكسايلت على سيناتور
الديمقراطيه الحاليه كاثرين كورتيز ماستو
التي تبدو انها ستخسر مقعدها اما في
جورجيا فسباق كان قريبا للغايه بين
سيناتور الديمقراطي الحالي رافاييل وارنك
والجمهوريه المدعوم من ترامب هيرش الووكر
قبل ان تعلن السلطات انها تتجه لجوله
اعاده للانتخابات مجلس الشيوخ في السادس
من ديسمبر اي جوله ثانيه اما على صعيد
انتخابات مجلس النواب فكشفت شبكه سي ان ان
عن حصول الجمهوريين على 2009 مقاعد فيما
حصلت ديمقراطيون على 191 متعدا
[موسيقى]
سبونج بوب
المقبل وهو سباق على مقعد عضو مجلس الشيوخ
بين رفيع
لجوله الاعاده
حتى يوم الاثنين الموافق الثامن والعشرين
من نوفمبر
[موسيقى]
تخلف مسؤول الانتخابات في ولايه اريزونا
عن فرزي اكثر من نصف مليون بطاقات اختراع
عبر البريد في يوم الانتخابات النصفيه
الامريكيه وحتى قبلها بقليل وقد يستغرق
الامر عده ايام قبل ان يتضح من الفائز
واكد المسؤولون للناخبين انه سيتم عرض كل
بطاقه اقتراع بعد ان ادى خلل في الطباعه
في حوالي ربع اماكن الافتراع في اكثر
مقاطع
بالسكان وهي ماري كوبا الى عمليه التصويت
هذا وحفظ الديمقراطيون على تقدم بينما
الجمهوريون متفائلون بان الاصوات التي تم
فرزها في وقت متاخر
ستكون لصالحهم بشده كما حصل على 2020
اما في ولايه نيفادا لا يزال من السابق
لاوانه الحديث عن حسم الفائز بها
واستتباطؤ في فرز الاصوات الذي قد يستمر
حتى الاسبوع المقبل وقال مسؤوله والتصويت
ان فرز البطاقات بطاقات الاقتراع بالبريد
الالكتروني سيستغرق اي من مع وجود مهله
امام المسؤولين حتى 17 من نوفمبر الجاري
لانهاء عمليات الفرز واعتماد النتائج
نقوم بالتحقق من بطاقات الاقتراع بالبريد
كل يوم حاليا في الموقع الالكتروني لدينا
9579 شخصا تم ادخالهم في عمليه التحقق من
بياناتهم ومن بين هؤلاء
5396 لم يتم التحقق من بطاقات قراءه من
بعد وسيستمر هذا الرقم في النمو حتى ننتهي
من معالجه بطاقات الاقتراع بالبريد
في غضون ذلك وعيد انتخابات نادي لوكا
ممثلا عن ولايه بنسلفانيا باغلبيه الساحقه
على الرغم من وفاته الشهر الماضي وان تخبر
الديمقراطيه ديلوكا وهو اطول ممثل في من
سلفانيا باكثر من 85% من الاصوات مع فرزه
98% منها وما حدث هو انه بحلوله وقت وفاته
كان قد فات الاوان لازاله اسمه من القوائم
الانتخابيه النصفيه الامريكيه او تقديم
المرشح اخر لمقعده وسوف يتم اجراء
انتخابات خاصه بالمقعد لتحديدي من سيشغله
من مدينه واشنطن ينضم او من واشنطن ينضم
الينا مراسل العربيه
ما هي التفاصيل حتى الساعه قبل ان نبدا في
شرح بقيه الولايات وخاصه تنسلفانيا حيث
كنت
انا قامت بدور مهم جدا بالنسبه
لديمقراطيين واصيب الجمهوريون باحباط كبير
خلال هذه الجوله اهم حدث في بنسلفانيا
تمكن اهم الانتزاع مقعد من الجمهوريين
لمصلحه الديمقراطيين في مجلس الشيوخ
الامريكي وهذا اعطى حضوره عاليه جدا
مجلس الشيوخ كل ما يحتاجونه هو 50 مقعد
ليصبح مناصفه مع الجمهوريين ثم تاتي نائبه
الرئيس على الملكيه لتعطهم الاخباريه
اعتقد انها قامت بدور كبير جدا خلال هذه
الانتخابات على عكس همم نيويورك التي خسر
فيها
الديمقراطيون على غير هذا بعض المظاهر طيب
يعني حينما نتحدث عن هذا الحسم حتى الان
ما زالت هناك ولايات لم تحسم حتى الان
ولايه قد يكون هناك التي عاده ثانيه الى
اين تتجه الانتخابات في مجلس الشيوخ خاصه
لدينا 50 مقعد للديمقراطي
ين الانتخابات بحسب الاحصاءات الاوليه
السبب يعود الى ان المرشح كاليفي ولايه
اريزونا متقدم على منافسه الجمهوري همم
اما همم
في ولايه نيفادا فهو متقدم على منافسه
الديمقراطي وبالتالي يصبح لدى الجمهوريين
50 مقعد يبقى المقعد المعلق هو همم
جورجيا وهم بالتاكيد سوف يذهبون الى جوله
اعاده في بدايه الشهر
كان متقدم بشكل قليل جدا على منافسه
الجمهوري له تمكن هذا الجمهوري من انتزاع
المقعد في جورجيا فسوف تكون الغلبه
والاكثريه في مجلس الشيوخ الامريكي همم
يعني اذا ما عدنا ايضا همم الى همم
سلفانيا
ما الذي حدث هناك هل تفاجات ديمقراطيون
بما حدثت في بنسلفانيا
وعفوا الجمهوريه
ان كنا
نتحدث بعد ما طبعت لوائح الانتخابات هذا
الموضوع عمليا هو ذكرته انت بكل تفاصيله
ما حذفه بانه لا يستطيعون اعاده طبع
الاوراق وايضا لو تم انتخابه فانه همم كان
من الواضح ان المؤيدين لهذا الحزب لا
يريدون اعطاء اصواتهم للحزب الاخر بل
ارادوا على احتفاظ بالمقعد ليتاكدوا من ان
اكثريه سوف تبقى الى جانبهم فلو صوته
للشخص الذي هو حي فانه سوف يكسب المخرج
طيب اليوم همم ايضا هذه
الاحاديث التي تصدر دائما من انه
الجمهوريون يقولون انهم فازوا في هذه
الانتخابات وهو تقدم جيد لكن البعض يا رب
ان الجمهوريين حتى في هذه الانتخابات
النصفيه لم يكونوا على قدر هذا الفوز
الساحق الذي قد يؤرق الرئيس في مقبل
الايام او قادم الايام
كانت التقديرات في بدايه الصيف ان
الجمهوريين سيتمكنون من اكتساح وقاعد
كثيره في مجلس الشيوخ وفي مجلس النواب
الامريكي وهذا لم يحدث هناك اشياء كثيره
تغيرت منذ ذلك الحين الان في افضل الظروف
سوف يكون الجمهوريون مسيطرين على مجلس
النواب الامريكي هم وعدوا بانهم سوف يجرون
الكثير من التحقيقات في اعمال الاداره
الديمقراطيه الحاليه ليس من السهل على
الجوهريين ان يعطوا بطاقه خضراء للرئيس
الامريكي في كل ما يريد فعله الرئيس
الامريكي يتحدث عن هذا الموضوع يوم امس
وهو ايضا تحدث الى زعيم الجمهوريين في
مجلس النواب الامريكي في محاولات من
الرئيس الامريكي الديمقراطي الجسور مع
كفن بكارثي وبناء علاقه بين السلطه
التنفيذيه ومجلس النواب
في للمرحله المقبله يجب ان نفكر ان
المرحله المقبله سوف تشهد مفاوضات بين
الرئيس الامريكي وبين الاكثريه الجمهوريه
الممكنه اكثر مما يجب ان نفكر انه سوف
تكون هناك مشاكل بين الطرفين من مدينه من
واشنطن مراسل العربيه في الغانم شكرا
جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
نشرتنا مستمره وفيها بعض الفاصل
الرئيس
مع الجمهوريين ويشد بالانتخابات النصفيه
حياكم الله حملت النتائج الاوليه
للانتخابات النصفيه تحديدا لموقع الرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب شخصيه مهيمنه في
الحزب الجمهوريه تسعى للعوده لتصدر المشهد
والترشح في الانتخابات الرئاسيه القادمه
اذا اشار تقرير لصحيفه واشنطن بوست ان بعض
مستشار ترامب اعتبروا النتائج الانتخابات
النصفيه جرحا في مستقبله السياسي
مضيفا ان بعض الحلفاء القدامى لترامب
يشجعونه الان على تاجيل اعلان الترشحه
للرئاسه الذي كان يخطط له الاسبوع المقبل
ونقلت الصحيفه عن شخص مطلع على المناقشات
كان يستطيع او يستطيع
مستشاريه حول قراره واشنطن بوستال فتاه
الى ان سبب الذي دفع مستشاري ترامب لتاجيل
اعلان ترشحه للرئاسه هو جوله الاعاده في
مجلس الشيوخ في جورجيا بعد تعادل المرشحين
بنسبه 50%
ويتلاقات ترامب وبقى الصحيفه اللوم من
الجمهوريين على الاداء المخيبي للامال من
قبل العديدي من المرشحين الذين دعمهم
قبل ذلك اعتبر الرئيس الامريكي السابق
دونالد ترامب بانا انتخابات التجديد
النصفيه كانت نصرا كبيرا جدا بالنسبه
للجمهوريين وقال ترامب انه اذا فاز
الجمهوريون في الانتخابات الكونغرس يجب ان
ينسب الفضل له معتبران ان ما سيحدث غالبا
هو العكس على حد تعبيره
من نجاته اكد الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدنا
انه مستعد للعمل مع الجمهوريين لضمان امن
المصالح الامريكيه بغض النظر عن نتائج
انتخابات التجديد النصفيه متعهدا بالعمل
على عدم عوده سلفه دونالد ترامب الى البيت
الابيض
بنت شاشه
تعرضت للاختبار والانتخابات النصفيه شهدت
افضل اداء للحزب الديمقراطي منذ سنوات
طويله الموجه الحمراء التي تنبا بها
الجمهوريون في انتخابات التجديد النصفي لم
تحدث ونتائج حتى اللحظه مخالفه لما توقعه
الاعلام والجمهوريون وانا مستعد للعمل مع
جمهوريين للضمان امن المصالح الامريكيه
بغض النظر عن نتائج الانتخابات وساعمل مع
الجميع لخدمه الشعب الامريكي وسادع قاده
الحزبين الاجتماعي في البيت الابيض
لمناقشه كيفيه العمل معا
وقال بعيدنا انه ينوي الترشح عالي ولايه
الرئاسيه الثانيه في عام 2014 بغض النظر
عن النتائج انتخابات التجديد النصفيه
مشيرا الى ان قراره النهائي عما اذا كان
سيترشح ام لا سيكون في مطلع العام القادم
وكمان
انتخابات هذا العام تمثل افضل انتخابات
نصفيه منذ عام
1968 واضاف لقد خسرنا عددا اقل من المقاعد
في مجلس النواب مقارنه باول انتخابات
النصفيه لرئيس ديمقراطيه منذ 40 عاما على
الاقل
معنا من واشنطن الدكتور عقيل عباس الخبير
في الشؤون السياسيه ومن القاهره الدكتور
احمد سيد احمد الكاتب المتخصص في الشان
الامريكي والعلاقات الدوليه اهلا بكما
ليبدا اولا من واشنطن مع الدكتور عقيل
عباس دكتور يعني هل بالفعل هذه الانتخابات
لهذه الانتخابات النصفيه ودعمه لمرشحين
بانه قلل من الخسائر التي كانت تكون عاده
بالانتخابات النصفيه الحاكم قد يخسر همم
نظره للسياسات المتابعه من قبل الرئيس
يعني هذا يوم
شكرا على هذه الاستضاف هذا يوم جيد
للديمقراطين اعتقد الذي ساعدهم ربما
الاستفزاز الذي مثله دونالد ترامب
الاعلانات التي قالها ومعها كان بعض
الجمهوريين بخصوص عدم القبول بالنتائج
مقدما اعتقد هذه لاعب دورها لكنه ايضا من
جانب اخر همم تصور انه هو همم الدعايه
الجمهوريه في الايام الاخيره كانت قويه
باتجاه تاكيد ان
الجمهوريين لا يمثلون خيارا افضل خصوصا
للنساء بسبب قضيه الاجهاض وما اليه مجموعه
عوامل هي اعتقد صببت في اخر المطار في
صالح همم الديمقراطيين اعتقد وجوده
الشخصيه الخلافيه
دونالد ترامب ساهم في اخراج عدد اكبر من
المصوتين الديمقراطين او المصوتين الذين
هم بالضروره ليسوا ديمقراطيين لكنهم
يشعرون بالاستياء
السياسه من جديد طيب هل معنى ذلك
يعني السيد الدكتور احمد هل معنى ذلك ان
دونالد ترامب لم ينجح في اداره هذه همم
هذه الانتخابات بدعم المرشحين وبالتالي
الانشقاق داخل الحزب الجمهوري اكبر من ضعف
الديمقراطيين خلال السنتين الماضيتين
صحيح تحياتي لك يا استاذ عادل والدتك
الكريم ولكل مشاهدي قناه العربيه الكرام
في الواقع ان الدول ترامب وهو بيعكس حاله
جدليه خلافيه ليس فقط في المجتمع السياسي
الامريكي ولكن ايضا داخل الحزب الجمهوري
يعني هناك جزء كبير من الحسبه الجمهوري هو
لا يتفق مع ترامب في توجهاته او في خيراته
السياسيه بل البعض يعني ربما اعتبهوا
اولاما رئيس ترامب عندما دعم بشكل صريح
والقى ثقه وراء بعض المرشحين وخسروا
الانتخابات وكان منه اشهرهم محمد اوزي في
ولايه بنسلفانيا وبالتالي هذا يؤثر على ان
الجمهوريون يرون ان وجود ترامب في المشهد
يعطي الزريعه والفرسه له الديمقراطيون ليه
التقطيع على الفشل وسوء الاداء الاقتصادي
والسياسات واللاعب على فكره ترامب ترامب
وفوبيا او او الظاهره الترابيه وان ترامب
يمثل تهديد الديمقراطيه
ويؤدي الفوضى وهذا مركز عليه الرئيس
بايرنغ حتى قبل الانتخابات وقال الخوف من
الفوضى وحشد حتى الرئيس اوباما واستحضره
وكل هذا يعني ان الديمقراطيون وجدوا ربما
المنقذ لهم في هذه الانتخابات ومنع تجنب
السيناريو الكارثه وهو اتساح الجمهوريين
لانتخابات مجلس النواب في اذهات ترامب
والتركيز عليها وبالتالي كان البعض او
داخل حزب الجمهوري يرون ان على ترامب ان
يلتزم وان يتقيد وخاصه ان ترامب هو
بطبيعته يعني ينحرف او يخالف ال- ال-
التريند العام او التيار العام في الحزب
الجمراء الجمهوري القائم على اعتبارات
السياسيه على الترشح هو يتصرف بانط حتى
رجل الاعمال وتصريحاته وبالتالي هناك حاله
من الانشقاق لكن مع ذلك يظل ترامب هو ايضا
عامل مهم في دعم وحشد الحزب الجمهوري وفوز
الكثير من تشريحيه هناك جزء كبير القاعده
مهمه من الحزب الجمهوري هي مقتنعه بترامب
ترامب هنا يعبر عن ظاهره وبالتالي ال- ال-
فكره شعار امريكا اولا وشعارات ترامب
وسياساته هي جزء كبير من الناخبين
والجمهوريين يقتنعون بها بل ان بعضهم حتى
الان مازال يقتنع ان الانتخابات الرئاسيه
في 20 20 سرقت وبالتالي وجود ترامب من
ناحيه هو ده يعني الحزب الجمهوري هو ايضا
عامل مساهم في الفوز وحتى بالاغلبيه في
مجلس النواب وان لم تكن اغلبيه كاسحه او
موجه حمراء كما كان يتوقع الجزء الاخر من
الحزب الجمهوري الدكتور همم اليوم هل ينجح
الرئيس الامريكي همم في التعاون مع
الجمهورينا وبالتالي مد جسور التواصل معهم
وعدم عزله كما هو يعني متوقع او اللجوء
الجمهوريين الى عذله واثاره هذه القضيه
مستقبل
دكتور عقيل
السياسيه في مجلس الشيوخ فاعتقد انه اذا
بقي مجلس الشيوخ ديمقراطين ويبدو انه سيف
قاعدين مع طارق بسيط ليس كبيرا في مجلس
النواب لا سيكون بامكان الديمقراطيين اي
يمضوا الكثير من اجندتهم السياسيه همم
هذا عامل اخر انا اعتقد هذا لم ينتبه له
كثيرا هو فكره المؤسسات واحترام المؤسسات
يعني هذا الازدراء الذي يقوم به
الجمهوريون او قسم كبير منهم باذعامه
ترامب الازدراء بالمؤسسات الامريكيه
بالمؤسسات الانتخابيه همم بالازدراء بفكره
الحكومه نفسها انا اعتقد هذه يعني بدات
يعني تظهر تظهر عليها ردود افعال سلبيه
بعيده الامد وان هناك جزء من المج
الامريكي يقول لك لا هذا المش هذا الجزء
كان عموما ساكتا صامتا لا يصوت هذا الجزء
همم يتم استفزازه اعتقد ظاهره الترامب
والتفاف المزيد من الجمهوريين حول لاسباب
مصلحيه همم تستفز الطرف الاخر على ان يدخل
في السياسه ويدخل في الانتخابات ويدافع عن
المؤسسات لانه هناك احساس ان هذه المؤسسات
تشتغل بالامكان تغيير الذين يقودونها
عندما يفشلون لكنه نقد ترامب الى ابعد من
البعض يرى بان هناك فجور في الخصومه حينما
كانت الديمقراطيون يمسكون همم يعني همم
بيزعامه الكونجرس هو بالتالي هم ذهبوا الى
ابعد من ذلك الى المطالبه بعزل ترامب
اليوم هو عمليه انتقامه انعاده
يعني اعتقد
جزء من هذا صحيح جزء من هذا صحيح ان ترامب
كان رئيسا مختلفا كسر المعايير
العامه
للرؤساء ظاهره غير مسبوقه يعني روتانا
وهو في الرئاسه بمؤسسات الدوله يتحدث مع
زعماء المؤسسات رئيس الاف بي اي والاخرين
يعني يطلب منهم ولاء شخصيا عدم الانتماء
فلذلك انا اعتقد الجمهور يفهم هذا يفهم
خصوصيه ترامب وخروجه عن ما هو معتاد
سياسيا في الولايات المتحده اتقد السعر
بهذا السياق لا ينطبق بدقه الدكتور همم
الدكتور احمد يعني باختصار اذا اذا تكرمت
اليوم حينما نتحدث عن ترامب ويقول من ان
هذا النجاح لن ينسب له سينسب الى اخرين
وهو يتخوف من ذلك الشيء ماذا يعني ذلك
دلالات على الحزب الجمهوري باكر
يعني بالطبع ترامب هناك يعني مساعي من
الحزب الجمهوري لنسب هذا الانجاز الى
الحزب وليس الى ترامب باعتبار ان هناك
قطاع من الحسبه الجمهوري يتجنب او
يخشى من ترامب ولا يتفق معه لكن انا في
اعتقادي ان الفوز الجمهوريين بالاغلبيه
تمثل نقطه مهمه لانه سنقل سينوي المكايات
السياسيه الديمقراطيون سيوقف كل محاولات
المحاكمات والعزل واستدعاء ترامب باعتبار
ان الديمقراطيون استخدامه الاغلبيه في
مجلس النواب خلال العامين المضيائي
للمجاهده السياسيه والشخص ترامب لكن في
زياره الوقت ايضا ترامب سيظل ظاهره موجوده
ترامب موجود هو بيعبر عن تيار كبير في
المجتمع الامريكي واعتقد ان هذا ما حدث في
انتخابات التجديد النصفي هي تمهد او تهيا
الطريق الى الانتخابات 24 وبالتالي الحزب
الجمهوري يعاني من ضعف شديد هيكلي
وبالتالي الاقرب والسيناريو هو ترامب وان
ترامب ما زال هو الرهان هو الذي سيقود
الحزب الى ربما انتخابات 24 كما كان له
دور دا يعني حتى وان كان ليس باغلبيه
كبيره لان الحزب الجمهوري لم لم يلك
قيادات او كوادر وانما بالعكس هو صعد على
اكتاف ترامب في انتخابات 20 وفاز
بالاغلبيه ايضا نتذكر في مجلس الشيوخ
ومجلس النواب كان هذا بفضل ترامب وبالتالي
هذا الجناح شدد او اتجاه ترامب اعتقد انهم
مع الوقت ومع المقياد السياسيه
للديمقراطيون هذا دفع التعاطف الكبير من
القاعده الجمهوريه وايضا من المترددين مع
ترامب وبالتالي نحن نشهد مسار جديد وعوده
جديده لا ترامب في الحياه السياسيه واعتقد
ان اعلانه الاسبوع المقبل له الترشح سيكون
ده تشين لهذا المسار وهذا الطريق رغم
المعرضه من جانب بايدينا الذين حتى الان
يلعبون على فكره الخوف من ترامب ليه
التغطيه على سوء الاداء الاقتصادي ومحاوله
الترهيب واستنفار
الامريكي تحت اعتبارات الفوضى والخشيه من
النظام
الديمقراطينا الدكتور عقيل عباس الخبير
فيها الشؤون السياسيه شكرا جزيلا لك ومن
القاهره الدكتور احمد سيد احمد الكاتب
المتخصص في شان الامريكي والعلاقات
الدوليه شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
قال الرئيس الامريكي
كنا نعلم ان القوات الروسيه في اوكرانيا
ستنتظر الى انتهاء الانتخابات ومن ثم
ينسحبون من خيرسون ما يعني ان لديهم بعض
المشاكل
اخرج موافق يعني
مع رئيس الوزراء البريطاني في لندن هكذا
ان انتخابات التجديد النصفيه الامريكيه لن
تغير من دعم واشنطير على ان اوكانيا
في امريكا
اعمل لكم
باي باي
منظمه الصحه
في انتخابات الكونجرس الامريكيه
الجمهوريون يقتربون من اغلبيه مجلس النواب
والمنافسه محتدمه على مجلس الشيوخ
الرئيس
الى البيت الابيض والاخير في مرمى
انتقادات الجمهوريه
بعد اعلان انسحابها الدفاع البريطاني تقول
ان روسيا دمرت جسورا وراءها في خير سول
لابطاء تقدم اخرى
السلطات الايرانيه تعتقل مذيعا وتتهمه
بالعماله ونشطاء يتظاهرون رغم تهديدات
وزير المخابرات وقائد الجيش
حياكم الله اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
سحب قواتها بشكل كامل من المنطقه الجنوبيه
في خير واعاده تمركزها على الضفه الشماليه
من نهر
وافادت الوزاره بان القوات التي تم نقلها
من خيرسون اعادت نشرها في نقاط اكثر اهميه
لدعم العمليات العسكريه واشاره الدفاع
الروسيه الى ان القوات المواليه لها سيطرت
على مدينه مدينه مرينكا شمال
الجيش الاوكراني ان القوات الروسيه تقوم
باعمال الهجوميه في باخ موت وفي بيك
المحتلون يغادرون وتتمثل المهمه الاكثر
واهميه بالنسبه لهم في تعزيز النقاط التي
يقومون بعملها حاليا في دينبروفسكي وبناء
على ذلك حول الطرق المؤديه الى خرسون وعلى
التوالي باتجاه سد كخوفك الكهرومائيه
وهداء لضمان انسحاب قوتهم وبالتالي يمكننا
القول ان انهاء احتلال منطقه خرسون قد بدا
بالفعل اليوم خرسون على شفاء ازمه انسانيه
الشيء الوحيد الذي يسمح لنا بالبقاء على
قيد الحياه وتعون المواطنين والمزارعين
واصحاب المشاريع الصغيره لكن يجب الاعتراف
بان اسعار المواد الغذائيه قد تضعف على
الرغم من ان الطعام لا يزال متحرك
في غضون ذلك قالت وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه
في تقرير لها ان قدره روسيا على الاحتفاظ
بقوتها على الضفه الغربيه لنهر دينيفرو في
خيرسون واجه الضغوطا بسبب الضربات
الاوكرانيه على طرق اعاده الامداد واضاف
تقرير ان القوه الروسيه دمرت اثناء
تراجعها العديده من الجسور ومن المرجح ان
تكون زرعه الغاما لابقاء تقدم القوات
الاخرانيه وتاخيرها وذكر التقرير ان
القوات الروسيه ستكون عرضه للاستهداف خلال
اجتياز نهر النيلرو لقله نقاط العبور
مرجحا ان تنسحب على مدى عده ايام مع تغطيه
نيران المدفعيه لعمليات التراجع
في واحده من اكبر عمليه الانسحاب الروسيه
التي قد تشكل نقطه تحول في حرب تقترب من
نهايه شهرها التاسع موسكو توجه قواتها
بترك الضفه اليمنى لنهر ديني برو في منطقه
خرسنا الاوكرانيه وتوجهيه ساره وزير
الدفاع الروسي امر بتنفيذ الانسحاب اقتراح
من قائد العمليه الروسيه في اوكرانيا
الجنرال سيرجيو روفيكن الذي اقر بانه ليس
قرارا سهلا الخطوه الروسيه جاءت بعد تعرض
خارج لهجوم اوكرانيا مضاد منذ اسابيع ان
شهدت مواجهات ضاريه في الايام الاخيره
عليها الرؤوس في اوكرانيا بالكامل منذ
اطلاق العمليات العسكريه في الرابع
والعشرين من فبراير الماضي
وكانت الى جانب ثلاث مناطق اوكرانيه اخرى
ضمتها اليها موسكو بعد استفتاء لقي
انتقادات دوليه واسعه في وقت ابدى فيه
الكريم لان استعداده للتفاوض مع اكياف لكن
مع مراعاه الحقائق في الوقت الراهن حقائق
بدات تتغير مثل ما حدث في خرسان بلال
الوجداني العربيه
الى ضبط المشاعر خلال الصراع معربا عن
ارتياحه لسيد المعارك في مناطق مختلفه
ده الفورماتين مبروك
عواطفنا دائما اثناء الحرب بالتاكيد لن
نفيد العدو بكل تفاصيل عملياتنا سواء في
الجنوب او في الشرق او في اي مكان اخر
عندما نجني النتائج سياره الجميع ذلك
من جهه اخرى
الروسيه من محاوله تفجير محطات الطاقه
الكهرومائيه والنوويه واعتبر ذلك بمثابه
حرب على العالمين اجمل
الان اريد ان احذر مره اخرى بشكل منفصل كل
شخص في موسكو يتخذوا القرارات ذات الصله
من اي محاوله لتفجير محطه كخوفك للطاقه
الكهرومائيه واغرق اراضينا وتجفيف محطه
زابوريجيا للطاقه النوويه سيعني ذلك اعلان
الحربي للعالم كله فكروا فيما سيحدث لكم
بعد ذلك
كشفت مصادر امريكيه مسؤوله عن رفض
الولايات المتحده طلبه اوكرانيا بمنحها
طائرات مسيره عاليه التقنيه من طراز جريل
وذلك صحيفه
ايضا جاء لتجنب تصاعد الصراع بين اوكرانيا
وروسيا على الرغم من تواصل الطلبات
المقدمه
وكذلك من مجموعه من اعضاء الكونجرس
الامريكي الذي طلب وزير الدفاع الودي
اوستن بنقل طائرات جريئه القتاليه الى
اوكرانيا
قال رئيس هيئه الاركان الامريكيه المشتركه
الجنرال مارك ميلي ان الجيش الروسي تكبد
خسائر بشريه تقدر باكثر من مئه الف جندي
سقطوا بين قتيل وجريح في اوكرانيا مشيرا
الى ان القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه عانت
على الارجح من مستوى مماثل من الخسائر في
الحرب ودعم روسيا واوكرانيا فرص المفاوضات
كما توقع هدوء نسبيا على الجبهه الروسيه
الاخرانيه في فصل الشتاء وقال ميلي لمنظمه
نادي نيويورك الاقتصادي ان هناك الكثير من
المعاناه الانسانيه التي تسببت بها الحرب
في اوكرانيا
معنى مانيكيبه وراجع رمضان رئيس مركز
الاوراس للدراسات الاستراتيجيه سيد رمضان
اهلا بكام اليوم حينما نتحدث عن ربما
مشاكل لدى القوات الروسيه وهي ما دفعتها
الى الانسحاب من خيرسون باعتقاده كم ما هي
المشاكل الحقيقيه التي تعاني منها القوات
الروسيه والتي دفعتها حتى الى تفجير هذه
الجسور وترك خيرسون رغم اهميتها
حقيقه هناك عده مشاكل للقوات المسلحه
الروسيه من اهمها صعوبه وصول الذخيره
والاحجار من القوه الحيه عبر النيفر عبر
لان هذه المنطقه تقع تحت التصويب المباشر
للمدفعيه الاوكراني وخاصه المنظمات
المتطوره التي تتعامل مع الاحداثيات التي
ترصد من طرف الاقمار الصناعيه كل التحركات
الروسيه
نهر النيبر من اجل تقديم الدعم لامداد
اللوجستي يقصف بطريقه مباشره ولذلك اصبحت
تلك المجموعه التي تقع على الضفه اليمنى
او الغربيه كما يقال ستصبح محاصره يعني
عاجلا ام اجلا ستكون في كماشه للقوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه التي لها الميزان كبير
وامدادات مباشره من الحلفاء من الغرب خاصه
ان وصلت هناك معدات وتجهيزات نوعيه اضافه
الى
عمل المستشارين من حلف شمال الاطلسي الذي
الذين لديهم تجربه عميقه في التعامل مع
هذه الخطط ولذلك حقيقه الروس يعني كانوا
يعانون الكثير وخاصه انهم اصبحوا يتعرضون
للقذف كما ذكرت هذا اولا ثانيا هناك خلل
فيما يعرف بالتعبئه الجزئيه يعني هناك عدد
قليل يعني نسبي مقارنه بالقوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه ولا لم تستطيع القوات المسلحه
الروسيه ان تغطي كل الكثافه بالعدد
بالضبات والجنود لكل هذا الخط التماس يعني
في هذه الحاله اخترقات سريعه التي تاتي من
ترك القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه تركت
الاوكرانيا
وتجسر نبض وتقدم ضربته
بالقوات المسلحه الروسيه وهناك همم يعني
السكوت لارواح
بعدد كبير يعني الاعلام الروسي يغطي عن
ذلك ولا يؤكد طيب هذه المساله يعني ما
قاله ما قاله ايضا همم قبل قليل كما
استمعنا الرئيس همم الاوكراني اليوم همم
هل باتت الفرصه اكبر بين البلدين للجلوس
الى طاوله المفاوضات
عقيقه الغرب ربما والدوله التي تاثرت من
هذه الازمه اقتصاديا هي تريد الذهاب الى
ولو تفوضات في جزء يعني انتقالي ولكن ما
هي الشروط هذه ما هي الشروط كيف سيتفاوض
يعني الطرف الاوكراني هو همم يعني راضيه
تحت الاحتلال اظن الذهاب الى التفاوض في
هذا الظرف والقوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه لها
الامتياز تذهب الى هذا الامر عصيب يعني لا
اظن ان ستكون هناك محاوله ناجحه للتفاوض
بين الطرفين غير ان قدوم فصل الشتاء فان
العمليات العسكريه نوع الماسك تتجمد نظرا
لاسباب الموضوعيه ربما سيكون هناك تفوق
بخصوص ملفات انسانيه تبادل الاسرى ربما
بخصوص ملفات تابع اقتصادي بخصوص بواسطه
بودره تسويق الحبوب ومسائل اخرى ذات طابع
لوجستي اقتصادي ليس اكثر اما المسائل
السياديه التي تخص الاراضي الاخرانيه
المحتله في الدوله الاوكرانيه لن تساوي
مولانا تراقب على هذه ولذلك فان المسافه
تفاوض يبقى ويضل عسير في ضمن هذه التي
نلمسها الان شكرا جزيلا لنا يا سيد رمضان
رئيس مركز الوراثه الدراسات الاستراتيجيه
الملكيه
افادت منظمه العفو الدوليه في تقرير لها
ان روسيا ربما تكون ارتكبت جرائم ضد
الانسانيه باجبارها المدنيين في المناطق
التي تسيطر عليها في اوكرانيا على
الانتقال الى مناطق اخرى مشيره الى ان
المدنيين نقلوا قصرا من مناطق اوكرانيه
الى اخرى تسيطر عليها روسيا مع فصل
الاطفال عن عائلاتهم في انتهاك للقانون
الانساني والدولي
اعتقلتها الشرطه الايرانيه مذيعا لقناه
ايران انترناشونال التلفزيونيه المعارضه
حيث اتهمته بالعماله قائله ان الاعتقال تم
اثناء فراره من البلاد وفق وكاله فارس
الايرانيه شبه الرسميه الشرطه وجهت
اتهامات للمذيع بانه ادار انشطه واعمال من
شانها تشويه سمعه ايران وتحريض الشباب على
التظاهر في ما وصف وزير الاستخبارات
الايرانيه اسماعيل الخطيب من جانبه القناه
التي تتخذ من لندن مقر لها بانها منظمه
ارهابيه على حد تعبيره
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
احتزمت على احتجاجات الايرانيه اليوم في
شوارع جنوب شرق البلاد وذلك بالتزامنه مع
ذكر حمله 30 متر سبتمبر في مدينه زهدانه
التي شهدت مواجهات داميه مع قوات الامن
التظاهرات جاءت على الرغم من تهديدات
اطلقها وزير المخابرات وقائد الجيش
للمعارضه داخل وخارج ايران وقالت منظمات
حقوقيه عن زياده الاحتجاجات سيتبعها مزيد
من عمليات القمع من قبل قوات الامن
دنيا
القدس قاسم سليماني في العاصمه طهران
[موسيقى]
وفي شاننا ايرانيين اخر اعلنا مدير
الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه
انتهاء المفاوضات مع ممثلي طيران فيينا
دون نتائج واوضح جروس حول الاتفاق النووي
متعثره مشيرا الى ان الايرانيين لم ياتوا
باي شيء جديد واكد روسي الوكاله الدوليه
سيتوجهون الى ايران في غضون اسابيع قليله
لمواصله المفاوضات
من جانبه شدد وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي
بينيجانس على ان بلاده لديها القدره على
تنفيذ عمليات ضد المنشات النوويه في ايران
وهكذا جراند سنه جميع الخيارات على
الطاوله لمنع ايران من حيازه اسلحه
النوويه وان اسرائيل تستطيع احداث اضرار
جسيمه لبرنامج ايران النووي وتاخيره
اكدت وزاره الصحه الصينيه انه لا معلومات
حتى الان تاكدوا عقد قمه صينيه امريكيه
بين الرئيسين
على هامش قمه العشرين في اندونيسيا وقال
متحدث باسم الوزاره ان الصين تاخذوا
المقترح الامريكي لعقد هذه القمه بجديه
واشار الى النصيب ملتزمه بعلاقات ايجابيه
مع الولايات المتحده لكن قضيته تايوان
ستظل في قلب المصالح الصينيه حسبته وشدد
المتحدث الصيني على ضروره تخلل الولايات
المتحده عن مواصفات بعسكره القضايا
التجاريه ودعمي اقتصاد السوق
في غضن ذلك رجحت وكاله تاسا الروسيه
مشاركتها الرئيس الروسيه بلادي مير بوتين
في قمه العشرين عبر الفيديو وذلك بعد ما
اعلنت السفاره الروسيه في اندونيسيا انه
لن يحضر القمه المقرره في بالي الاسبوع
المقبل على ان يكون وزير الخارجيه سيرجي
لابروف ممثلا لوفدي بلاده
اعلنت منظمه الصحه العالميه تراجع وفيات
كورونا عالميا بنحو 90% منذ فبراير الماضي
وقال مدير عام منظمه الصحه
انخفاض وفيات كوبيد مدعال التفاؤلفه الى
ان معدلات اختبار فايروس وحمضه النووي لا
تزال منخفضه في جميعها انحاء العالم
واعتبر المسؤول الاممي ان الثغرات في
عمليه التطعيم لا تزال كبيره والاستمرار
في انتشار المتحورات الجديده امر مقلق
داعيا الجميع على الحصول على التطعيم
الكامل ضد فيروس
في نهايه الشهر هذا تذكرهم بابرز العناوين
في انتخابات الكونجرس الامريكيه
الجمهوريون يقتربون من اغلبيه مجلس النواب
والمنافسه محتدمه على مجلس الشيوخ
رئيس بالعمل لعدم عوده ترامب الى البيت
الابيض والاخير في مرمى انتقادات
الجمهوريين
بعد اعلان انسحابيها الدفاع البريطانيه
تقول ان روسيا دمرت جسور ورائها في خير
سولي اطفاء تقدم اوكرانيا
السلطات الايرانيه تعتقل مذيعا وتتهممه
بالعماله ونشطاء يتظاهرون رغم تهديدات
وزير المخابرات وقائد الجيش
شكرا لكم المتابعه واترككم في رعايه الله